I'm Christina yes I am the executive
secretary sensations bring our movement
on climate change is the Secretariat
which was imparted in Germany and we are
just coming out of a very successful
meeting in durban south africa here in
the whole school i am very very
impressed here from so many particular
private companies who have said despite
the crisis despite what the newspapers
are saying they see a huge opportunity
to invest much more into clean
technologies they see into the future
they seem young Vietnam crisis and they
can see that that word that is red
larger size and I've been very impressed
with a very positive spirit that I have
seen here with the most second point
that I would like to make is how are we
actually going to get to this
transformation that we need to have
where it already doesn't into a folk art
society right there I think really one
of the most important movers and shakers
of that transformation is these views is
the up and coming by consumers so you
are much more aware however you recorded
the environmental company what you're
buying and the question for me is how do
we reach out to the people of you to
have you culture in through social media
through whatever other channels you
think are important how do we help
reassure in the new economic structure
that we are